graham crackers often best when paired
with melted marshmallows and chocolate
but it didn't start out as a sugary
snack originally they tasted like
cardboard and they were intended to curb
your sex drive it all started with
Sylvester Graham a 19th century minister
who believed that alcohol meat and fatty
foods led to greed lust and sexual urges
and well that had to be stopped
Graham's cure was simple he preached
that bland foods would curb sexual
appetite and he developed a cracker made
of unbleached flour wheat germ bran and
definitely no sugar
voila the graham cracker was born
Graham's theory and his crackers gained
a cult-like following his loyal devotees
called themselves graham IDEs but as
time wore on Graham's theories tipped
the scale of extremism and eventually he
lost his popularity he died in 1851 and
that's when the graham cracker began to
change over time it went from many
modifications until the National Biscuit
Company now known as Nabisco came around
and successfully sweetened the bland
cracker with some honey and sometimes
cinnamon and chocolate however you
choose to your graham cracker don't
leave out the marshmallow
you